it's funny the films I thought would
probably be Marvel's failures Thor and
Captain America everyone kind of knew
we're gonna be okay and they were right
however for me the film I thought would
be okay but everyone thought was going
to be a failure was guardians of the
galaxy I guess I can kind of see where
they're coming from this is a weird
setup we go from super heroes and super
gods to intergalactic fugitives one
being a tree and one being a raccoon
with a machine gun yeah it's pretty
silly but I guess I knew it'd be okay
because it kind of embraced its insanity
the marketing said everything this is
not meant to be taken that seriously
it's a raccoon who swears it's a tree
that can only say three words
it's a giant gray guy who literally
doesn't know what sarcasm is it's the
chubby dude from Parks and Recreation
suddenly made to look like a beefcake
this is gonna have a good sense of humor
and it did and people seem to love it
though from the beginning you might
think something else it starts off with
our hero named star-lord watching his
mother die from cancer
she asked him to take his hand he's too
afraid doesn't grab it and she dies
he runs out into the field screaming
because he lost his mother and suddenly
he's abducted by aliens that sounds like
a totally insane opening and it is but
it's a totally insane film years later
he grows up and finds himself living
among the aliens as a bounty hunter
treasure hunter pretty much anything
hunter that's usually illegal but he
gets mixed in with a plot from another
boring bad guy you won't remember God is
Loki really your best villain why is
Marvel so bad at these and he teams up
with a group of Outlaws to try and stop
it
nobody was demanding to see this movie
on the big screen hell nobody even
really knew that much about these
characters but that's sort of what made
it so interesting and new we didn't know
these people we weren't gonna get upset
if they weren't represented a certain
way and nobody really had high standards
because who the hell's reading a comic
about of raccoon with a machine gun
that's what the real question is why
were we reading a comic about a raccoon
with a machine gun but nonetheless when
the movie came out everyone went nuts it
was one of the biggest hits of the
summer and everybody adored it and
yeah I like it too did I love it I don't
know if I can say that I like a lot of
the other Marvel movies more but I think
because people standards were set so low
they were surprised they enjoyed it as
much as they did for me that I thought
was a lot of fun and funny but I don't
know if I see it as quite the big
masterpiece that a lot of other people
are seeing it as the plot once again is
obviously a filler plot it's talking
about the Infinity stones it has a
throwaway villain there's a bunch of
characters that we're gonna see later
oh hey there's Thanos and he still does
nothing but big well maybe it's like
Winter Soldier and it just does it so
well well it does it okay again this is
supposed to be a comedy so it's a
different kind of mood and it does have
more sentimental scenes but they kinda
come out of nowhere maybe that's the one
issue with the movie is the pacing now
that's too fast or too slow they just
don't always segue into each other very
well there's a really nice scene where
Groot lights up this room with all these
little lights but it's suddenly an
emotional scene in this really big
action-packed moment and it just sir
comes in and leaves too fast there's
another scene where the raccoon is
drugged and suddenly starts a fight and
we go into a little bit of his backstory
and again it just kind of comes out of
nowhere they're nice scenes they just
don't always fit in I'm also not sure
why they never made this green lady that
funny everybody has their own little
weird quirk but she's the only one that
doesn't really seem to have anything
that funny about her you could make the
argument that she's the sourpuss who's
grounded but we kind of had this big
great guy for that well maybe she's the
more emotional center well know we kind
of got star-lord for that so yeah even
though she looks kind of cool I didn't
entirely see the purpose of her I would
have liked something a little extra to
make her feel like she's more part of
the team but again it's kind of a
nitpick and what's obviously supposed to
be a silly movie and as silly movies go
I don't know what else to really say
about it it's good it has good effects
it has good acting it takes itself
seriously at the right moments and goes
for the all out laughs and other moments
is it clumsy at times yeah but look at
it's a raccoon and a tree I'm surprised
we got any of this out of that I'll
admit I don't think I loved it as much
as everyone else did but I thought oh
really enjoyable as goofy intergalactic
comedies with a lot of action go this
one's pretty good its creative it's
weird its goofy and it's got a lot of
punches and explosions grab the next
ship to the Stars and see for yourself